now when the characters come alive like
that you kind of know where the story is
headed but then the characters come
alive and yes they do take the story in
different directions some of the
carrier's do that their perverse little
creatures and they will throw you a
curveball can you give us an example of
where one of the characters who stole
the story and drove it in their own
direction okay well in the first book in
a game of Thrones there was a crucial
point where an assassin tries to kill
bran in his bed and he's defeated and
they get this dagger man it's a very
unusual dagger the stark family by then
has split does Ned Stark has gone south
with the king and he's taken with him
his two daughters while Catelyn Stark
his wife is still at Winterfell with her
sons Robb and bran and Rickon and many
of the family retainers this is seen
where they meet and my intention wasn't
Catalan would send a messenger with the
dagger to Ned Stark in King's Landing to
try to unroll this difficulty but as I
sat down to wrote this scene Catalan
wouldn't do it he wouldn't send a letter
you know she was going to go herself
someone had tried to kill her child and
they it was the dagger and she wasn't
gonna yes I'll write a very strong
letter and send it off and I'll pick
this minor character as a messenger no
that was something that she was going to
do herself and that threw me for a bit
of a loop because again in my original
thought she was remaining at Winterfell
kind of history of the north but some
part of me knew the character better
than the part that had done that initial
plotting I don't really believe in this
mystical stuff you there's some wall to
talk about with it you know we use it as
a shorthand with the characters talking
to us at a character saying things it's
really one point of your mind talking to
another part of your mind it's all
coming from the altar but maybe it's a
right-brain left-brain kind of thing but
whatever is a creative part of the brain
is not necessarily the analytical part
and it knows better sometimes
the analytical part may devise plots but
the creative part is the one that gives
the heart and soul to the characters and
it overrules the analytical parts
sometimes that conflict within the mind
that listening to other people in your
head when you played also that very well
in a story ages ago which my mind is now
forgetting the title story of the person
on a gateway their guardian at a gateway
science fiction I'm a wild cover story
yeah yeah that was one of my very
earliest stories the title was again the
second kind of loneliness yes yes I
totally forgot the title but there you
had a character who is playing off
against the voices in his head mm-hmm
dealing with that being on the edge of
insanity as a writer does it make you
nervous listening to people talk in your
head no it makes me nervous the idea
that might stop I mean it is interesting
to see how writers go to hell of course
you always hope it won't happen to you
that you'll just get better and better
until the day you die at 137 but of
course it happens to most writers not
all of them there are writers like Jack
Vance who's one of my favorite writers
who I think is writing just as good as
he ever was and this stuff is terrific
and I buy every Vance novel and read it
the minute it comes out there just
reprinted his dying earth series yes
wonderful wonderful read seminal fantasy
series the dying earth deserves to be
mentioned along with middle-earth and
Howard's Hyborian age as one of the
great settings of fantasy publishing a
very small edition in the early 50s by
an obscure miner house called Hillman
and yet its effect on later fantasy is
incalculable but putting Vance aside as
an exception
I do think many offers go to hell later
in their lives and the ones who are very
analytical rational things go to hell
their books become lifeless you get a
sense as you read each book there's just
like the book that came before
that they're rewriting the same story
over and over again they're just going
through two paces you know they've read
too many stories about outlines of how
to write a novel and now they're doing
it on the other hand the writers who
have depended more on the creative part
perhaps who haven't been quite so
analytical what tends to happen to some
of them is they just fall silent
suddenly someone who's been a very
prolific writer stops writing and you
don't see any new books from them I mean
you look at rate of like Theodore
sturgeon tremendously prolific early in
his career and then suddenly he's taking
20 years to write his last novel and
it's still not complete when he dies or
Walter M Miller you know how many
decades when you work on the equal to
canticle for Leibowitz and now finally
it had to be completed by another writer
after his death ever he committed
suicide yes yes and from all reports
that I've heard there really wasn't much
more to be done there was only a little
bit more to be done and yet somehow I
found them sometime we'll to do it so
the fear not of the voices in your head
the fears that some of the voices will
go silent and then you better hope you
have a lot of good stocks and bonds when
you're starting a story do you think of
characters and situations do you think
of a situation and playing the
characters to fit the situation do you
come up with an image of something
do you pose a clown I don't but I'm I
sit down and I know I mean the ideas
come to you they don't come to you
sitting in front of the computer they
come to you where they come in all times
you know when you're lying in bed just
before you go to sleep and when you're
riding on a train or in an airplane or
when you're driving in traffic it's
really it's a time when you're alone in
some sense or maybe surrounded by people
but you're alone you're not engaged in
conversation and the ideas come to you
so hopefully you write them down
sometimes you forget them if you don't
write them down and then when the moment
comes to work on them you kind of take
out your idea book or your notes and say
hey not this one no I'll see what I can
do with this one
in a book with multiple viewpoint
characters 89 viewpoint characters and
you've got all these story threads that
are weaving in and out sometimes two
threads will weave around each other and
then separate and even if it's tapestry
that you're weaving do you sit down and
write all eight nine you point
characters simultaneously or do you pick
one and kind of follow that one through
and then figure out where you're going
to divide and mix everything together
I'm sort of trying to write two chapters
in the order in which you're going to be
read but it is true I don't often stick
with that for a very well I usually get
into a groove on a particular character
and of Tyrian or Aria whoever it may be
jobs snow and suddenly I start writing
exclusively from a few points of that
character I'll finish a Tyrian chapter
and the next chapter is supposed to be
bran or someone but instead I'll skip
ahead and do the next Tyrion chapter
maybe skip ahead and do the next here in
Chapter after that well go as a reader
what I'm really into a story I'm really
into what's happening to a character I
have known to flip ahead to read the
next chapter for that character
well you shouldn't do that happen it's
okay for me it's not good for you well I
do it anyway you're a reader you're
supposed to follow them in the order I
give it to you I'm a bad reader if your
characters could change the direction of
the story I can change the direction of
the read because things happen in
between in the chapters of other
characters but impact on so you may find
out things that you didn't want to know
what happened yeah but sometimes you
just can't help yourself also of course
I find myself constantly rearranging the
order chapters I mean I start out with a
kind of rough outline of you know how
the chapters will fall you want to try
to come back to every character kind of
semi-regularly
because otherwise the reader is likely
to forget that they exist but I
discovered very early on in the process
that you couldn't do it rigidly yeah I
started out in the first book initially
I had a structure you know I had like
seven characters initially and I was
gonna you know every seventh chapter and
yeah then it would always be the same
order each character would have a
chapter seven chapters apart it didn't
work at all because sometimes one
character is right in the midst of all
the events in a lot
things are happening to him and another
character is in a quiet portion of the
story and not much is happening and
sometimes the chapters only cover a day
and sometimes they cover six months so
you know you really have to look at them
hard and you have to vary the kind of
approaches you take to them I'm always
struggling the chronology you know
should I present the chapters in
chronological order or the other
question is for dramatic effects I mean
sometimes cutting back and forth in
certain ways get some interesting points
and counter points there's internal
cliffhangers as well as the cliffhangers
at the end of books I frequently try to
end a chapter on a cliffhanger or a
chapter on a new development or a plot
twist and you want some other chapters
in-between so there is sometimes you can
use the chapters in between fifty let
the reader have a breather
oh yes yeah that happens too you want to
avoid the second Indiana Jones
phenomenon where there were so many
things piled on top of each other that
after a while it's just like poof right
I don't care right yeah definitely I
enjoy when you've got a book like these
where you've got a lot of characters a
lot of scope and characters can go
sometimes for a book without interacting
and then as the books move on to where
the conclusion certain characters
suddenly start getting closer and closer
to interacting it well for the most part
all the characters were together when
the first book began and have gone their
separate ways I said most not old it was
always Daenerys was always off on a
different continent and they're
spreading further and further apart but
of course toward the end some we're
going to have to coming together again
so so do you find that adding a new
viewpoint character makes it more
enjoyable for you because it lightens up
the writing by having some new friend
yeah there's an element to that it opens
a new aspect to to say a few point
character gives you not only a new
friend but it gives you an entirely new
way of looking at our new pair of eyes
to look at your old friends because the
new viewpoint character has different
knowledge and may have a different slant
on many at events that have gone before
so suddenly the reader who has been told
that a character is like this or
something happened
particular way here's a very different
way of looking at things and asked to
step back and say whoa and maybe make a
reappraisal look and think about it
which I like my readers to do and my
readers are great at doing this I have
some of the best and smartest writers
some of the websites that are set up and
devoted to Ice and Fire they keep
amazing news groups and bulletin boards
and things like that going and they
write me with questions that they've
argued about and some pretty interesting
discussions that they have there they're
very sharp and they do think about it a
lot and I like that because you want to
read a ship who notices the subtleties
that you're sweating to put into the
book and this is one way of getting at
them I mean I'm a big believer aggregate
points too many of us as we read these
books believe everything that we're told
by the author and we shouldn't we should
often Ally and while authors lie in the
characters line and then to the extent
that you're inside a character's head
you have to realize that you're getting
his point of view of what's going on and
the author should never lie in anything
that's factual where he's describing the
world thing the Sun is coming up well
you don't say the Sun is coming up if
this one is not coming up but it's a
pretty day that's the character giving
an opinion on it you know mm-hmm and it
might not be such a pretty day to a
different character the Ice and Fire
series has inspired incredible amounts
of commentary at all major places yes
it's great what is it about this series
of yours that has inspired so much more
discussion than other books that you've
done well I mean compared with my other
series I think the biggest difference is
that it's ongoing open-ended series I
mean most of my previous novels have
been single standalone novels so the
reader reads them in one sitting or
several sittings close together and then
they're over when a work of art is
complete there's not much to discuss and
you know where it's going you can't have
arguments or discussions about this is
where I think it's going or this is the
kind of pocket of element that I want to
see because you know you've read it you
know what's going to happen it's already
happened
a serious theft is still in the process
of going on I think allows the readers
to participate a lot more in that kind
of having that kind of discussion
the only phenomenon that I've seen
anything like what we're getting on on
the Song of Ice and Fire previously that
I was connected with was the wild card
books which were also an open-ended
series that was on a much smaller scale
of course since those books did not have
the huge audience of the ice entire
books are getting but still many wild
cards fans and it was quite a popular
series for time would have the same
kinds of vigorous discussions about who
their favorite characters were and who
were good guys and who were bad guys and
what should happen next and what they
didn't want to happen next
etc and we see that at conventions when
we would do wildcard panels conventions
just the feedback from the readership
while you're in the middle of an ongoing
series does that ever influence what you
do with the series the direction of it
you know somebody writes no no one coven
I try not to let it anyway I don't
actually read the bulletin boards
precisely because I know if I did read
the bulletin boards it might have an
influence and might have an influence
both ways I mean what I read on the
bulletin boards might influence the
books and my presence would inevitably
influence the bulletin boards instead of
the readers arguing with each other it
would all become sort of question for
mr. Markin sort of saying where they
were looking to me to answer questions
or resolve things I'd rather have them
discuss it with each other than just
make it a sort of a internet question
answer but I do get emails of course
from the fans so even without going into
the bulletin boards I hear some of
what's going on these emails I do try
not to let myself be influenced by that
because I think you get in trouble if
you do I mean like you set out with a
book for example I'll give an example
from the Ice and Fire series the
incident I mentioned or anyone we were
talking about Catelyn where an assassin
is sent to kill Brand
and it's a mystery for most of the first
two books who sent this assassin and I
know the fans had many many discussions
about this and the answers that I was
revealed in the third book I solved that
particular mystery it's part of the
closure of that book but for first two
books it was unresolved so the readers
were free to suspect this one or suspect
that one and to make their arguments
about who they thought did it now
inevitably there are only two be
generous to be extremely generous about
a dozen likely suspects for this you
know maybe only a half-dozen who are at
all logical and another half-dozen who
would be like extreme long shots so when
you have several hundred people
discussing an arguing and inevitably so
long that I'm going to hit on the right
answer and maybe convince the others and
you know then you have a situation where
everybody knows the right answer or at
least you could get that impression if
you were up on the board so what do you
do then is the offer do you do change
the answer because gosh they've all
figured it out well that's not going to
be very good you know well you don't you
can't if you're influenced by that
you're gonna get very unsatisfying
things because you've already laid the
groundwork for the first answer and it
was that groundwork that led whoever
figured it out to figure it out and now
if you start changing that that you know
you're changing the rules of the game in
the middle and you're Russell providing
I think an unsatisfying artistic
experience I've always thought I mean
I've never met George Lucas I've never
had a chance to actually sit down and
talk with him about any of that but I've
always wondered whether Lucas wasn't
perfected by his audience to some extent
because I think if you look at Star Wars
they're clearly things being set up by
that suddenly changed abruptly
in the later movies I don't believe that
he set out knowing that Luke and Leia oh
brother and sister I think if you look
at the first movie they were clearly
meant to be a love interest with each
other but the audience responded much
more strongly to Han and to Luke you
know that was part of it and I don't
think that Darth Vader was even
originally Luke's father
obi-wan clearly says in the first movie
he killed your father just to seem to me
admits to any really double meaning I
think again it was a case where Lucas in
between films changed his mind perhaps
in response to the audience that started
deepening things I think for a book or
film or any artistic endeavor like that
to be satisfying it's got to have a
single author a single vision and as
soon as the audience is guiding and
directing what happens you've lost the
single artistic guidance right and you
end up with dear God television which is
surprising that it's as good as it is as
often as it is considering what you have
to do to do it